Yeah,
the way I think about attention is
really as a problem of routing routing
signals,
so actually we know a lot about how
signals come in through your sensory
apparatus,
through your ears and your eyes.
We know an awful lot about how the
retina works,
how the Cochlea Works,
we understand how the signals travel up
and eventually they percolate up to the
cortex.
In the case of sound,
they percolate up to the auditory cortex
and we know a lot about a fair amount
about how they look once they get there
and after that we kind of lose track of
them and we can't really pick up the
signal until we're.
They're coming out the other end.
We know a lot about movement.
We understand an awful lot about what
happens when a nerve impulse gets to a
muscle and how muscles contract.
That's been pretty well understood for
50 years or something.
You're more than that,
so where we really lose track of them is
when they enter into the early parts of
the sensory cortex and when there we
pick them up again,
sort of on the on the other side,
and so attention is one of the ways in
which signals can find their destination
if you like.
So think about it in terms of a really
specific a problem.
Imagine that I asked you to raise your
right hand.
When I say go,
okay,
so I say go you raise your right hand,
go raise your right hand.
Now let's change it.
And I say,
go raise your left hand,
go raise your left hand.
So somehow the same signal coming in
through your ear is producing different
activity at the other end,
somehow the signal on the sensory side
had to be routed to either the muscles
of your right hand or the muscles of
your left hand.
Now,
attention is a special case of that kind
of general routing problem at the brain
faces all the time because when you
attend to,
let's say your a sounds rather than your
visual input or when you attend to one
particular auditory input out of many,
what you're doing is you're selecting
some subset of the inputs in this case,
coming in to your ears and and
subjecting them to further processing
and you're,
you're taking those signals and routing
them downstream and doing stuff with
them.
How that routing happens.
That's the aspect of attention that my
lab focuses on.
So,
so the basic setup for the problem that
I'm interested in is this.
Imagine that you're at a cocktail party.
There are a bunch of conversations going
on and you're talking to someone,
but there's all this distracting stuff
going on.
The side lines.
You can make a choice.
You can either focus on the person
you're talking to and ignore the rest.
Or as often happens,
you find that the conversation that
you're engaged in is not as interesting.
And uh Huh.
Uh Huh.
Oh really?
Summer.
Okay.
And you start focusing in on this
conversation on the right,
your ability to focus in on this
conversation while ignoring that
conversation.
That is sort of the challenge.
Understanding how we do that is the
challenge of,
of my research and that,
that problem actually has two separate
aspects.
So there's one aspect of that problem
that is really a problem of computation.
It's,
it's a problem that is a challenge to
basically any computer,
namely,
uh,
we have a whole bunch of different
sounds and from a bunch of different
sources and they're super imposed at the
level of the ears and somehow they're,
they're added together.
And to us it's typically pretty
effortless for us to separate out those
different threads of the conversation.
But actually that's surprisingly
difficult tasks.
So a computers maybe 10 years ago
already,
we're getting pretty good at doing a
speech recognition and in,
in a controlled situations and quiet
rooms.
Computers were actually pretty good at
recognizing even a random speakers,
but when people actually start deploying
these in real world settings where
there's traffic noise and whatnot,
the computer algorithms broke down
completely.
And it was sort of surprising at first
because that's the aspect that we as
humans seem to have a not much trouble
with at all.
So the,
the,
uh,
ability to take apart the different
components of an auditory scene,
that's what we've evolved for hundreds
of millions of years to do really well.
Um,
so that's one aspect of attention.
There's almost this sort of,
um,
uh,
aspect of it that happens before we're
even aware of it,
where the auditory scene is broken down
into the components.
The other aspect,
which is,
uh,
the one that we're sort of more
consciously aware of is the one where
out of the many components of this
conversation,
we have this auditory seem.
We select one and that's the one we
focus in on,
right?
So it,
at this hypothetical cocktail party,
uh,
we have the choice of focusing on either
the conversation we're engaged in or
this one or that one.